throughout the original eight season run
of dexter dexter morgan made some pretty
questionable decisions we're looking at
you hannah mckay keep watching to see if
the moments you flipped out over made
the list
when leading a life fraught with
compulsion and bloodshed there will
always be moments when things go awry
dexter learned this rather quickly at
the start of season 3 when tracking a
drug dealer by the name of fred freebo
bowman destined to be the next occupant
of dexter's kill table the operation to
nab freebo is a bust as dexter must kill
an innocent man out of necessity in
self-defense dexter kills oscar prado
the younger brother of assistant
district attorney miguel prado while
freebo escapes naturally dexter
manipulates the crime scene in an effort
to frame freebo i went to kill freebo
and ended up killing a total stranger
dexter eventually hunts freebo down and
kills him meanwhile miguel is also on
the prowl in an effort to seek revenge
for the death of his brother when dexter
confesses to miguel that he killed
freebo miguel is relieved and the two
begin a friendship on the foundation of
murdering criminals the ugly truth that
dexter is in fact oscar's killer takes
the entire situation to another level it
requires him to frame another man for
the act while lying through his teeth to
his newfound friend over the ordeal
after it's revealed the dexter
orchestrated the arrest of rita's
ex-husband rita incorrectly assumes that
dexter is also a drug addict yes i have
an addiction
as a result dexter attends narcotics
anonymous to continue the lie while
attending the meetings he meets lila who
becomes a sponsor quickly lila
demonstrates a rather manipulative
element of her personality as she
coaches dexter to accept himself despite
his sins while she doesn't know of
dexter's dark passenger she understands
that he harbors a secret eventually rita
finds out about dexter's relationship
with lila and breaks up with him later
dexter learns that lila also has a
strange fixation as she is something of
a pyromaniac and sets her apartment on
fire to manipulate dexter eventually she
attempts to blackmail dexter into
getting back together with her all while
deborah learns that her real name is
lila west and she has a criminal history
eventually lila kills sergeant doakes an
innocent man in an effort to protect
dexter simply put dexter should have put
a stop to her dangerous actions long ago
sergeant doakes always had it out for
dexter he suspected the titular
character of being strange and likely
hiding something and he wasn't wrong in
fact he eventually learns the truth
about dexter morgan when dogs tries to
arrest dexter the serial killer
overpowers the sergeant and locks him in
a cell at a remote cabin at this point
dexter lays it all out on the table and
tells the sergeant that he is the bay
harbor butcher ultimately dexter commits
to evading law enforcement by framing
dokes as the serial killer dexter then
kills one of his targets in the cabin in
front of dokes after he witnesses the
shock of the police sergeant toward his
bold crimes he starts reflecting on his
past
that's when dexter realizes that harry
actually committed suicide because he
couldn't cope with his son's actions
despite teaching him the code and trying
to protect him the sergeant's shock
reflects what harry must have felt and
dexter considers doing the noble thing
which would be turning himself in
unfortunately for dogs lila finds the
remote cabin and burns it to the ground
with dogs and any evidence proving
dexter is a serial killer inside the fbi
then concludes that dokes is the bay
harbor butcher allowing dexter to walk
free while a moment of introspection
almost leads dexter to do the right
thing he still originally planned to
frame an innocent man for murder that's
low even by dexter's standards
while dexter's relationship with rita
begins with the sole purpose of
providing him with the camouflage he
needs to hide in plain sight it
eventually flourishes into some form of
legitimacy unfortunately however his
sociopathic nature leads to many
cringe-worthy decisions early in his
courtship with rita one egregious
example is when he plagiarizes his
marriage proposal from a killer who
romanticized a non-existent relationship
in her head my life was an unanswered
question
unanswered question
while this killer may have been far too
forthright with her delusions of love
dexter is the exact opposite therefore
he lifts her words and uses them as his
own when seeking rita's hand in marriage
once again for the benefits it affords
him
dexter had his fair share of ups and
downs but he always took pride in
following harry's code to the letter
however during the season 4 episode
slack tied the miami pd is hunting for a
killer after finding the arm of a model
inside the belly of an alligator this
turns dexter on to jonathan farrow a
photographer who takes twisted pictures
of female models who all appear tortured
or under duress
even i'm disturbed by this
dexter becomes intent on nabbing pharaoh
before the miami pd finds the evidence
that they need to make the arrest he
gets the suspect on his infamous kill
table the photographer adamantly insists
that he never killed anyone and that his
photographs are merely art dexter pulls
the trigger anyway and hacks the man to
death with a cleaver later he sees
detective batista taking pharaoh's
assistant into custody and charging him
with the murder of the women unbeknownst
to dexter uncovered surveillance footage
actually incriminated pharaoh's
assistant thus dexter was burdened with
the harsh reality that he killed an
innocent man
while dexter often lacks remorse he
demonstrates guilt over the idea that he
betrayed harry
season 4 of dexter is often considered
the best in the entire series and for
good reason john lithgow plays one of
the most captivating antagonists of the
series in the form of the deadly trinity
killer the murderer arthur mitchell is a
tortured soul who went through a
traumatic experience equally as
traumatic as dexter's in his youth as a
young boy where he witnessed the death
of his sister and the suicide of his
mother he also grappled with his
compulsory need to kill his abusive
father at the age of 10. this moment
ultimately completes the trinity killing
template that arthur uses annually with
three innocent victims this is where it
all started
the trinity killer's identity as arthur
mitchell surprises dexter he learns that
arthur is a family man who contributes
service regularly to his local church
arthur also leads a charitable
organization known as four walls one
heart which he uses to construct homes
for the less fortunate ultimately dexter
quizzically wonders how arthur can
maintain the balance of leading two
totally separate lives instead of
killing trinity dexter decides to don
the fake alias of kyle butler and
infiltrate arthur's congregation in an
effort to educate himself on how to
better lead a normal life outside of his
killing rituals quickly however dexter
learns that arthur is a rather abusive
father who behaves erratically
maintaining a healthy balance isn't
possible and dexter plots to kill him of
course the miami pd is closing in on the
killer putting dexter against the clock
tragically if dexter had killed the
trinity killer when he first learned of
his crimes the deaths and despair that
followed wouldn't have occurred
in the debut episode of season 5 dexter
prepares for rita's funeral after coming
to grips with his own grief and regret
he enters a convenience store and
crosses paths with a charming individual
who is pounding the bell at the counter
for a restroom key and threatening to
defecate on the floor after reaching
behind the counter and finding the
bathroom key himself he brushes past
dexter locking eyes with him and making
an untoward comment regrettably for this
hot-headed fool he spouted off at the
wrong place and time
dexter's sense of self-control is at an
all-time low as he struggles to pick up
the pieces of his shattered life the
killer follows the man to the bathroom
and explains to him that the weak hasn't
been kind thanks to the death of his
wife the man makes another unsavory
remark about dexter's deceased wife and
then quickly receives several blows to
the head with the blunt end of a boat
anchor while the foul-mouthed vagrant
was possibly deserving of many things
insults and ravings aren't exactly
worthy of a death sentence it's
definitely not dexter's finest moment
and it marks the first time ever that he
kills an unvetted person solely on
impulse and emotion
in season seven of the show the walls
are closing in on dexter morgan captain
laguerta is leading the charge in a
persistent effort to exonerate her late
partner sergeant jokes of the bay harbor
butcher name laguerta makes it
frighteningly clear that she intends to
nail dexter to the wall after her first
attempt at arresting him goes belly up
thanks to some careful planning on
dexter's part i have proof he's the bae
horrible butcher
seeing that she simply won't quit dexter
plans the unthinkable a premeditated
murder that defies the code entirely
dexter has violated the code in the past
but the plot to kill laguerta feels
especially dirty given the lengthy
professional and sometimes personal
relationship the two shared over the
years dexter lures laguerta to an empty
shipping container at the docks he
prepares to stage a scene that makes it
look like hector estrada and laguerta
killed each other deb arrives and as
legueta attempts to convince deb to kill
dexter deb kills leguerta instead in an
effort to protect himself and his sister
dexter ultimately breaks his father's
code with the plot to kill an innocent
police captain while simultaneously
ruining debra's life
in season seven the most significant
volatile variable to enter dexter's life
is hannah mckay you obviously want
something you keep making excuses to see
me
quickly the two share a connection her
past is of particular interest to dexter
as she joined a controlling boyfriend on
a killing spree if he were to believe
hannah's story she was forced into
complicity however dexter suspects that
hannah was just as involved and thrilled
about the killing spree as her murderous
partner after carefully investigating
dexter renders hannah unconscious and
binds her to his kill table however
after dexter tells her that murders are
the very thing that fuels his existence
she simply tells him to do what he has
to do finding a kinship in her dexter
cuts hannah free the two then proceed to
have sex on the kill table despite her
magnetism attracting dexter and her
unwavering commitment to harrison hannah
proved to be pretty unlikable with fans
plus seeing dexter succumb to hannah's
apparent charms while she was on his
table isn't exactly what audiences
expected and for a person whose soul is
rather empty he should at least keep the
kill table sacred
ultimately rita was an unfortunate
casualty in the deadly game of cat and
mouse that dexter played with the
trinity killer the ugly truth of the
matter is that rita's death is on
dexter's hands for tampering with forces
he couldn't comprehend even he didn't
know what trinity was capable of until
he was fully immersed in his fake
persona as kyle butler where he
witnessed trinity's social and familial
interactions firsthand in order to
protect rita the most obvious choice
would have been for dexter to simply
never get himself involved with the
trinity killer in the first place but of
course that would have made for an ultra
boring show and we all know that
dexter's compulsive killing habits mean
that he can't simply leave things well
enough alone the next best option would
have been to never give in to his
infatuation with the trinity killer and
his methods for leading a double life if
dexter didn't treat arthur like some
sort of twisted mentor maybe he could
have killed arthur a bit earlier before
the two even got entangled regardless
dexter's drive to kill and his
admiration for trinity were ultimately
the causes of rita's death at trinity's
hands it was a difficult lesson that
dexter had a hard time learning but old
habits die hard
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]